There’s recently been a dilemma in the MacBook
Pro world.
Do you buy the base 13” MacBook Pro for
a crazy good deal right now, or do you wait
for the rumored 14” model that’s supposed
to come some time next year?
The answer to that question is different for
each person and their specific use-case, but
in this video, I’ll give you 5 reasons why
you should buy the base 13” MacBook Pro
right now.
Reason #1 is that it’s currently on sale
for a huge $200 off on B&H, and if you order
now before it goes out of stock again, you
get free next day delivery depending on your
location.
That’s right, you can get a new 2019 MacBook
Pro for the same retail price as the MacBook
Air, which is an excellent deal.
For reason #2, there’s a good chance that
if Apple released the 14” MacBook Pro next
year, they may only update the higher-end
$1800 model and leave this base $1300 model
completely the same.
Why?
Well, in 2018, that’s exactly what they
did.
They updated the $1800 model to a quad-core
processor, better graphics and they gave it
the touch bar, while keeping the $1300 2017
model exactly the same for another year, with
the old dual-core processor and older-gen
butterfly keys.
But that’s not the case with this base model
that’s currently on sale for $1100.
It actually gets a quad-core processor and
graphics that’s almost as powerful as the
$1800, and it blows it away in terms of performance
per dollar.
We actually recommend that most people do
not buy the $1800 model, but seriously just
buy the base model because it’s basically
just as powerful.
And if you take that into consideration, why
would Apple upgrade both the $1300 and $1800
models to the new 14” display and new Intel
10th gen processors at the same time?
There still wouldn’t be much of a difference
in price and we would still recommend people
to just buy the base model.
Being Apple, it would make more sense to upgrade
the higher-end 13” model first and keep
the base model the same, because honestly,
you’re already getting a ton of performance
for the price.
So if this ends up happening, you’ll be
extremely disappointed if you waited for close
to a year for the 14” and you found out
that you have to pay at least $1800 to get
it instead of buying the base model right
now for only $1100.
**********
Now before we get into reason #3, let me tell
you about our sponsor, Squarespace.
If you've been thinking about making your
own website, Squarespace is seriously the
best way to go.
I built an engaging website for my wife's
cleaning business with literally no web-making
experience.
You just choose a template, customize blocks
of text and images and easily move them around.
It's incredibly simple, affordable, and it's
been running flawlessly for almost two years,
bringing in new clients thanks to its built-in
SEO tools.
So whether you're making a website for a small
business or for LITERALLY anything else, go
to squarespace.com for a free trial, and use
our custom link below when you're ready to
launch to save 10% on your first purchase
of a website or domain!
*********
For Reason #3, this base model has the 4th-gen
butterfly keyboard.
Now I know that makes you want to skip out
on this model altogether, but you may not
know that with this version of the butterfly
keys, Apple replaced a few of the key materials
with more reliable ones, and since the 2019
models, there has yet to be any reports of
failed keys.
Yes, the new Magic keyboard feels a lot better,
but the main reason that Apple has switched
to the new Magic keyboard on the 16” MacBook
Pro is because people don’t trust the name
“Butterfly keyboard” anymore, so Apple
had to completely ditch that name for people
to feel more comfortable about purchasing
a new MacBook.
For Reason #4, the performance boost going
from this models 8th gen CPU to the new 10th
gen isn’t that much.
We’ve already had our hands on two Windows
laptops that pack Intel’s 10th gen processors,
the Surface Laptop 3 with the lower-end i5
CPU and the XPS 13 2 in 1 with slightly better
i7 CPU.
Looking at multi-core processing performance
in Geekbench 5, the score only went up by
around 400-800 points depending on the chip.
That’s 10-20% more CPU performance, which
honestly isn’t that big of a deal.
Now for graphics, we get a much bigger difference,
from a score of 7358 up to 10434, which is
around a 40% boost in graphics performance.
That’s definitely a good reason to wait
if you’re a graphics user, but for those
of you who don’t do any kind of graphics
work, there’s no reason to wait.
For Reason #5, technology is always moving
forward, and yet there are people who wait
for years and years because they keep hearing
rumors of better MacBooks being worked on.
The truth is, you’re gonna have to buy one
some time, and Apple WILL release a better
model with better value eventually.
My take on it is that instead of sitting around
and waiting for 6 months or maybe even close
to a year, you can buy a MacBook Pro with
excellent performance right now and enjoy
it for all of those months that you would
have been waiting.
Those extra months of enjoyment are worth
it even if Apple releases a 14” MacBook
Pro next year, and if they only update the
higher-end $1800 model to 14 inches, you’ll
be extremely happy that you got this base
MacBook Pro for only $1100.
If you disagree with me, go ahead and voice
your opinion down below in the comments.
But if you agree, we’ve got links in the
description below to this excellent deal on
this MacBook Pro, so act fast before it goes
out of stock.
If you’re not already subscribed, click
that circle above because we’re starting
our coverage of the Mac Pro tomorrow!
So thanks for watching, and we’ll see you
tomorrow!